this is a fun fact about the Royal
Wedding fun fact if six members of the
royal family die Megan Markel will
become the queen of England that's a
weird yeah second second fun fact that
used to be Prince Harry's pickup line
stick around he used to go to bars just
take six take a chance some royal
wedding guests are already selling their
gift bags on eBay yeah yeah in fact
today Queen Elizabeth made 60 bucks
cleaned up I did
that's my Queen Elizabeth impression
former President Obama and mrs. Obama
have just signed a multi-year deal with
Netflix meanwhile meanwhile President
Trump has just signed a multi-year deal
with Melania so just sign it lets go
come on it's nice new Starbucks
announced that people may sit at their
tables and use the bathroom even if they
don't purchase anything good yes
Starbucks said if just one person buys a
venti latte our costs are covered for
the year the expensive place
actor Hugh Grant what you want to
transition there's no transition I ain't
got time for transitions we're on good
behavior tonight after a few grant is
marrying the mother of his three
children yeah this news comes as a shock
to the mother of his four children
[Applause]
I didn't like the earlier - but that was
the New York Police Department is
investigating allegations of sexual
misconduct against celebrity chef mario
batali yeah they're also investigating
Guy Fieri for crimes against the :
I can't believe this a man was arrested
for urinating on a seat during a
Frontier Airlines flight yes the first
time anyone has ever associated Frontier
Airlines with number one
[Applause]
you